your character is a psychic but she also
has some trouble navigating the present
i'm not supposed to see my own future
it's never happened before i was married
with a kid no way
you have to like talk to people to get
married
so how would you describe how maggie's
visions of the future kind of affect her
present though and like the things that
in the relationships she's trying to
pursue well she
she assumes she knows a lot of things
that you know she often finds out she's
wrong later on you know um especially
when it comes to ben who is her love
interest and the pilot and then she
thinks she sees them ending up together
but then she has another vision so it's
like she's only getting bits and pieces
she kind of uses her abilities as an
excuse not to really be in her life and
in the present moment and i i think it's
actually a really good way to
explore how i think especially
millennial women you know as we're like
navigating this like okay am i going to
get married do i want to be married i
don't actually have to do that if i
don't want to do like who do i want to
be with but if i want to have kids and i
want to have them with a person like am
i making the right choice it's like all
of this like yeah pressure decision
making think about fear right and it's
like well sometimes like your life is
just the experience of living it and you
got to be there and you can't be so
afraid of making mistakes or
being with the wrong person i just want
what everybody wants really at the end
of the day to unhook our bras and eat
noodles over the trash there's this
tight-knit group of close friends too
that she you know starts to develop too
how much fun was it to film with this
cast it looked like you guys who had
been friends for like years yeah and and
nicole sakura and i really clicked right
off the bat she's hilarious by the way
she's so i feel like her performance
reminds me of lisa kudrow and friends
like she thought even phoebe yes
oh my god i think she's hysterical okay
so if she's a phoebe maggie is the
sometimes i feel like maggie's got a
little bit of chandler in her i'm not
gonna lie kind of like the
self-deprecating maybe a little cynical
right you know okay i see that yeah i
love that now how do you feel about
psychics and mediums like are you into
that kind of stuff totally okay i mean i
think you know
i don't want to know
too many details but sometimes i think
you know
talking to someone who's like i see this
for you or
i see this about you can help you hone
in on your own intuition
and really figure out what you actually
want because a lot of us doubt ourselves
we doubt our own thoughts we doubt our
own feelings and we vacillate between
various choices and so yeah i think that
why not after starting the show how do
you think you would do if you knew your
future or knew it was coming up ahead
that would be hard it would be hard i
think it would be really right yeah and
i think that's why maggie gets so
freaked out by that because normally she
doesn't see herself yeah in visions and
in the first episode it's like the first
time she's ever seen her own future and
it really
throws her for a loop so can we talk
about maggie's fashion a little bit oh
yes i mean it's really good it must be
fun for you to get dressed up right oh
my gosh so pam chilton who was the
costume designer and i had
the best time i wear a lot of vintage
she pulled a lot of stuff from the fox
vault and they you know because of ryan
murphy they had some like really cool
stuff from the 90s so i wear a lot of
vintage 90s belts and jackets i wear
this really cool leather fringe jacket
from the 90s and um i also wear this
dress in the prom episode that's one of
a kind it's vintage it's incredible
you're pulling some scream queen stuff
too like did you see the stuff from the
ryan murphy collection
everything we could she was like i kind
of feel guilty i was like how fun is
that did you get to swipe anything or
keep anything um yeah i got to i kept a
few things like this like some pairs of
earrings i don't think i kept any of the
vintage i think that's like all scanned
and stuff
i love it you know what they want that
back right right uh well one thing i
wasn't expecting when i was watching
this show were a couple of nods to your
eyebrows which are iconic right
we're just talking about this in the
makeup room what is the secret to the
rebecca brow
okay the secret is
that i don't pluck them and then i just
use
this brow gel that i just i just brush
them up and shape them give a little
tiny bit of fill in you know go with the
natural vibe of it and just don't done
don't touch them too much i just feel
like any time i've really let someone
touch my eyebrows it's
that's the best advice i got they're
like don't touch it just don't cause i
always thought i got them threaded once
in new york and my dad was like
what happened to your face okay so
maggie ends on a bit of a cliffhanger
now without giving it away what was your
reaction when you first read that i
don't give anything away but it's sort
of like what we're rooting for you know
and it's i think it's so good because we
you have this arc of like where maggie
accepts
that
maybe the person that she was
hoping to be with or that she felt she
was destined to be with like you know we
all go through that experience right
where you're like maybe this thing that
i thought was meant to be isn't meant to
be and i'm gonna move forward
um
but then there's some twitter
then there's a twist i mean i was
excited i was that is life i did not see
that coming so does that mean we're
hopeful for a second season we're so
hopeful for what's going on we need to
know okay what would you like to see the
story go oh i'd really like to see
maggie maybe get a little bit
you know how in emma
she's a bit of a matchmaker oh yeah i'm
like what if maggie tried to do that
she would probably mess it up
which is why
that's a perfect storyline for a comedy
series i don't know if maggie has it in
her you know i was like you know she's
like what if instead of this rule where
i don't meddle in my friends lives i
just do that change my mind
i would love to see that actually full
meddling that'd be really fun well in
the meantime we have the first season to
enjoy i think fans will really really
get a kick out of this so
congratulations thank you thanks for
having me